Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
loki season 2 first look video mobius's dream of
the jet ski in the 90s is still alive because
they just released a new clip of the main loki
at a jet ski store so i'll explain
what's going on there's a bunch of
other big news and footage that dropped from
loki season 2 as well so we'll break it down
if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos i'll be doing episode videos for
season two just like i did for season one
she-hulk episodes are also starting this week
too i'll be doing videos for all those episodes
as well we're doing a disney plus giveaway for
memberships all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and post all your theories about loki
season 2 on the video but the new clip that marvel
was filming that just released is literally
loki at a jet ski store referencing this huge
joke of mobius talking about his dream of
the jet ski from the 90s this is the clip
foreign
so what's happening in this clip is that loki has
jumped through a tva portal or been pushed through
one in front of a jet ski store called like
piranha watercraft it's like a jet ski dealership
basically the reason why he's moving like this is
because he's being attacked by someone through the
actual portal and they'll just add the portal with
special effects later in post-production i can't
tell if mobius is also going to be featured in any
part of this scene next to the jet ski tour like
piranha jetski but i do love how they've turned
this whole jet ski meme fantasy to the next level
if you don't remember what the whole meme about
the jet ski is about like why is he so obsessed
with jet skis in the early 1990s for a brief
shining moment there was a beautiful union of form
and function which we call the jet ski the greater
meaning behind his dream of jet skis were meant to
explain what he was doing and where he came from
when the tva basically arrested him and mind wiped
him and turned him into another tva agent years
ago the tva exists out of time so technically when
you're inside the tva time doesn't pass for you
the same way so as long as they keep mind wiping
you periodically you'll just forget how long
you've been there and think that it's only been
a little while so that's how you can have people
there who they've just arrested and people who
have been there for hundreds thousands of years
and still think that it's only been a little while
and if you become too much of a problem like if
you remember too many things mind wiping doesn't
work they'll just send you to that trash planet at
the end of time basically where a lot of loki's go
if it wasn't clear they weren't killing people
or timelines or anything like that they were
basically sending entire timelines entire people
to this place at the end of time where a life
would eat them it just seemed like they were
disintegrating things so when mobius said that he
dreamed of jet skis and loki found all the jet ski
magazines at his desk those were clues that he was
from the 1990s like he was obsessed with buying
a jet ski love jet skis he hadn't bought one yet
and before he could while this is still in the
90s he did something to cause a nexus event became
a variant of himself and the tva arrested him
wiped his mind and then turned him into another
agent the whole thing during season one and i'm
sure this will continue during season two as
people start to remember things about their past
because everybody at the tva is a variant you saw
this towards the end of season one to like their
memories start to creep back on them slowly which
is why kang would have them mind wipe periodically
hunter b-15 went through the same thing she
started remembering things about her past asking
sylvia about them even ravonna renslayer started
remembering her life working at a school if that
wasn't clear the main version of rensselaer on
the show also a variant like i said everybody is
a variant there gugu m'batha raw also said that
renslayer would go down a much darker path during
season two brensler in the comics is mostly known
as kang's love interest for a little while they
work together like she helped him for a long time
then eventually he got tired of ruling over his
own chronopolis like his city at the end of time
basically and gave it to her and just went off to
do other things so a lot of her storyline during
season one was sort of setting the background
for that like she worked as an administrator at
a school so she kind of became an administrator
of the tva so to speak slowly working her way up
through the ranks in the whole idea at the end of
season one before sylvie had killed he who remains
version of kang he sent her secret instructions
that she then followed as she was escaping through
that portal the whole idea is that he knew that
loki and sylvie would either kill him or replace
him and he would eventually either way need
her help in the new version of the timeline
so a lot of what she's doing at the beginning of
season two is the path laid out for her by kang
before he was killed by sylvie we also got a bunch
more scenes of loki and sylvia at that mcdonald's
in the 1970s there's a couple different outfits
that you see them in like you see silvia obviously
wearing a version of the mcdonald's uniform like
she's working there and loki shows up wearing his
tva uniform like he's also chasing someone down
here this actor here raphael casal is supposed
to be playing a version of zaniac in multiple
episodes which is a reference to some scenes that
we saw in another video that i did i'll talk about
him in a second too but it's like they come to
this mcdonald's in the 1970s trying to chase him
down and silvie also happens to be working there
one of the funny things about silva you remember
from season one is that she uses apocalypses to
hide from the tva's detection so that kind of
implies the fact that she's working here at
this 1970s mcdonald's that an apocalypse is going
to be happening here at some point in the future
r.i.p mcdonald's you can clearly see he's really
happy to see her like he's kind of surprised that
she's there she's got a brand new haircut she's
also got a version of her leather regular costume
from season one so it seems like she just swaps
back and forth between different costumes and
then eventually either goes with him or goes to a
different place escaping again so it's just meant
to be confirmation that she did survive the end of
season one a lot of people wondered what happened
to her she stole kang's special temp pad that he
used to manipulate time travel so that's how she
escaped just to explain the zaniac character
he's being played by raphael casal here like i
said supposed to be a relatively big character
throughout season 2 maybe in a couple episodes
our main loki from season one is with mobius and
they're in 1970s london attending a movie premiere
and the movie zaniac is a huge easter egg
because zaniac is an actual marvel character
from the comics but in the marvel universe zaniac
was kind of like the essence or the spirit of a
serial killer who would possess different people's
bodies across time using supernatural means the
reason why they're using him on the loki series is
because he appeared for the first time in the thor
comics and this is loki so obviously thor
connection you get it but the star of the
movie brad wolfe is another easter egg because
in the marvel universe in the comics he was just
a regular actor who signed on to play a fictional
version of the zaniac character in a movie inside
the marvel comics but then when he was dressed
like the zaniac character they started filming
the movie doing his scenes he had an accident
and was mutated into the actual zaniac character
possessed by a spirit turned into a killer tried
to kill a bunch of the crew members until thor
stopped him and they threw him in an insane asylum
so if you remember the guardians of the galaxy 2
deleted scenes with a wonder man character played
by nathan fillion like he played a version of that
character in the universe but he was an actor
pretending to be these different characters so
they're kind of doing the same thing it's the same
energy with this zaniac movie but basically during
loki season two it seems like they're doing a
version of that zaniac origin story except when
the actor gets turned into the real xenia going
crazy trying to kill a bunch of people it's loki
who stops them from killing everyone instead
of thor and if you zoom in enhance on the movie
poster credits here for all the other actors names
the production crew members names the production
company is listed as a goodman production that's a
huge easter egg for the origin of the marvel comic
book company itself originally the company was
owned by martin goodman who owned timely comics
that was the original name of marvel comics he's
the one who hired a young stan lee jack kirby all
those classic era marvel creatives that you know
then later the company changed his name a couple
times eventually changing it to marvel comics
they've used this type of easter egg in marvel
productions before they used it during moon night
too when they're revealing the true origin of the
stephen grant persona that he was a character in a
fictional movie called tomb busters the production
company of that movie on the poster was listed as
timely atlas productions that was another easter
egg for timely comics but what happened is is it
started out as timely comics then in the 1950s
they changed their name to atlas comics then after
that they changed their name to marvel comics it
seems like what happens after they have this big
premiere event like that's in an earlier episode
he turns into the zaniac character or he goes
crazy like zaniac does in the comics and becomes
possessed and then goes on the run and that's
where they find him in a following episode at
this 1970s mcdonald's the other cool thing
you may have seen is that giancarlo esposito
confirmed that he had actually met with marvel
back during loki season one because marvel asked
him to play a character and it was meant to be
like a one-off character during season one he
said it was meant to be a one-off role and it
was a version of loki i think that meant that
they wanted him for the version of classic
loki that we saw richard e grant playing i'm
glad that it was richard e grant because he did a
fantastic job as that older classic loki character
giancarlo esposito said that he turned them down
because he wanted to play a much bigger character
at marvel which i think is probably a smart move
he specifically referenced benedict cumberbatch
doing the same thing and coming back as marvel's
doctor strange so originally if you don't remember
a long time ago marvel wanted benedict cumberbatch
to play a version of malekith during thor of the
dark world that didn't work out at the time but
that was before he kind of blown up in a really
big way internationally as a huge star then they
came back to him after that had happened to play
their doctor strange and obviously the rest is
history malakith was probably one of the weakest
marvel villains just in general that they've
done in the mcu so i think he dodged that bullet
metaphorically and literally but everyone post all
your loki's season 2 theories in the comments when
we get some more footage i'll do another loki
season 2 video it's not going to air till next
year so it's going to be a little while we might
get a teaser trailer by the end of the year or
early next year at some point marvel is doing a
special disney plus day next month where they're
going to be releasing a bunch of trailers a bunch
of footage making a bunch of big announcements
about what's happening in marvel phase 5 with
the movies the disney plus series so whatever
trailers they drop whatever announcements they
make of course i'll do videos for all that stuff
my she-hulk episode 1 video will post later
this week after they release it make sure you
enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss
that everyone click here for that other loki
season 2 first look video and click here for
my new she-hulk world war hulk trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!